[Music]
are you intimidated why are you
he said he took a run before this
because he was nervous now no because
i've been on a lot of podcasts but like
they're usually kind of small you know
it's like i see you guys as like joe
rogan for business so it's like there's
one step but wow above is like joe rogan
and then there's you guys and then below
it's like yeah i don't want to dis all
the podcasts i've been on they're
amazing but you know like this is like a
level so uh but it's good you know i
mean computer levels so
and you also don't know what sam might
ask you because sam might just come out
of left field and be like but that's the
thing i was thinking like sam is like
he's not a regular uh interviewer you
know he adds some crazy [__] so wait me
first of all i i don't know if that's
true i don't know if we first of all
it's not just me it's you too sean that
asks weird stuff but also
i don't think we asked that weird
questions i think we asked the questions
that everyone's thinking
no that's true but i mean you're not
just man like you know there's yes man
podcast where like they just it's kind
of like a fan thing obviously that's not
you guys you have real [__] real
questions and that's i think it's more
interesting as well
can we sam can we share the thing you
were just telling us in slack can i
share that on here on the pod yeah which
one
the sampar strategy for networking this
is um
you know you can go to harvard you can
go to stanford
you're not gonna learn this one
like you know it's a very small little
tweak but it's just so sam that it just
is awesome so if you're if sam wants to
hang out with you he'll text you just
like a normal person would but and he
doesn't need to even know you he's just
like interested in you maybe maybe it's
a cold dm maybe it's a text message
maybe he got your number from somebody
else like hey it's sam
uh you know i'm in san francisco but
instead of saying wanna hang sam will
just go i'm in san francisco let's
do this
he sent me some [__] that i won't
say out loud but yeah but i think it
worked
yeah
so sam what
what is this and why does it work so
well it's like a phrase like you know
like people will be like uh you know i
[__] with that guy like i [__] with
drake i like drake
it extends from that and i just say it
and people uh they reply i don't know i
just yeah this particular one i it was a
ceo of a multi-billion dollar company
who i'm friendly with i just said what's
up i'm in your hood let's
andy goes down when
like it worked out it's amazing
and now
so normally we try to play cool but
we've actually been chasing you peter
we've been we've been talking about your
projects we've been being like hey we
got to get this guy in the pod sam is a
fan of you for sure i would say i am
less of a fan than sam but i am a that
doesn't mean i like you it's just i'm
more in the closet about it whereas sam
is very open sam's like this guy's
amazing this guy's like an artist thanks
man this guy's got great hair and you do
have great hair so it's all true and now
we finally got you here and it was hard
i think right because you like don't do
you don't schedule or something like
that like
i mean it it like it looks like being an
ass right on instagram if you do that
but i
like like you guys i would get so many
dms and they're all like
i mean generally they're very low
quality dms right like i want to
collaborate but i don't want to invest i
don't want to
like people want something from you i
think it's like being a hot girl in the
club like people want something for you
but they don't want to invest the time
to actually get to know you or you know
you feel like an object and i don't like
to feel like that and i want to um
spend more time with you know like with
my friends in real life with uh my
girlfriend or something i want to spend
time on in the gym you know on my health
and cooking food and and that kind of
stuff go for walks and
uh i think because i
because i've been doing this for 10
years like startups like eight years and
now i get the money is going well so i
don't really need to do any calls
anymore any dms so i'm just trying to
create a more chill life
and i'm not an [__] it just means
like i don't have time to met to reply
to everybody so i close my dms and
and then people get really angry on
tweets they're like why don't you why
you close your dms are you arrogant and
stuff so i wrote a blog post like kind
of explaining my day and my routine and
what i do in the day and that i don't
really have time if i do all the things
i do now to also dm everybody reply
everybody and do calls and stuff
um and that's pretty much the argument
or even let's give the context so let's
explain who the heck you are so
uh your name is peter lovells you're
known on um twitter as levels io right
yeah that's the uh that's the right way
to say it i saw you a while back i'm
just gonna say some interesting things
about you i believe that you can correct
me if i have any of these wrong i
believe you publish how much you make
every year and in fact it's in your
twitter bio in your location there's
like a meter
that's like your road to three million a
year
yeah and it says 2.7 million so your
meter is almost all the way filled up
um you build a bunch of
random small projects usually around
some things you like or believe or your
lifestyle which is kind of a nomadic
lifestyle so i believe
i think you you you hop around or you
don't have like a home base so you live
you know you could be like in bali and
then you could be in the netherlands you
could be a different place all the time
and you make these small websites or
apps
and
it says in your bio that you have 13
million monthly active users
um and i've i remember seeing you
because you did a community like a like
a nomad community a slack community
really early on like slack had just come
out
and i was like this guy's like charging
10 bucks i think it was 10 bucks a month
or something to get into this thing i
was like he's got like a thousand people
here wow this is actually this guy's
making good money doing this um like
just by making a slack group and you
just do a bunch of small experiments
like that um that's what i know sam what
did i do
i'll give
pe peter let me give like the outsider's
perspective that's a little more
holistic so basically there's two things
that are interesting to you the first
one is your businesses which actually
are the least the lesser of the two
interesting things so you have roughly
five or s yeah you have seven different
businesses uh ranging from nomad list
which makes uh 2.1 million dollars in
the last 12 months that's a that's a a
job board you have another job board
called remote okay that's making 115
dollars a month you have read mate read
make which looks like it's like an ebook
something like that yeah it's like an
ebook yeah yeah 60k a month then you
have got like a bunch of really you're
seeing these numbers because he
publishes them where do you publish
these he publishes all of them on like
the the url uh go to his twitter profile
and we'll let you talk sorry peter in a
second but go to his profile
go to his twitter profile and then like
click off and it's like uh open revenue
at the very bottom but i'm reading off
of our notes so and then you have like a
qr menu creator then you have like an
inflation chart which doesn't seem like
it makes money but tracks uh inflation
and then you have rebase which is a
platform to help people become a citizen
of uh portugal help them re relocate the
portugal so what's the first part is
those businesses like i said you have
those that are interesting i would
narrow it down to say you have a series
of job boards for nomadic or remote work
that are
pretty profitable but the second thing
that's even more interesting is the way
that you do these things so you do a few
things that are interesting the first
thing is i think you're the only
full-time employee right and you use a
team of contractors and second of all
you have this weird personality
that's very
embedded in everything you do so that's
kind of like my big intro of what you do
i could see a website and i could know
you built it without you having an about
page which is kind of
clunky right it looks a little no it's
like no but it doesn't have a nice way i
guess yeah it's another designer yeah
no i think it's accurate description um
it's like like i'm not very nomadic
anymore like i'm slowly settling down
right but i started very nomadically i
was like moving around every month
um
i started like in 2014 i started
nomading and i uh went to all these
places and i started building these apps
these little websites little products to
validate and
i remember i mean i told the story so
many times but i was following patrick
mckenzie patio 11 on hacker news famous
hacker news a guy and now he works for
stripe and he would do he would share
his revenue on his blog about all his
little products he made and it was like
appointment reminder for barbershop so
you got to sms just before your
appointment so you don't forget it that
kind of stuff and i was really inspired
like okay this is not like some big vc
funded guy
he's just like an indie guy was just on
his laptop kind of building stuff
and i kind of mixed that with the nomad
thing where like building from your
laptop from your backpack moving around
i think also getting inspired from
different places because if you move
around you i mean i know sam moves
around a little bit as well uh
you
your life becomes very unique because
you meet different kinds of people you
you're in different kinds of places you
see different kinds of products like in
shops like if you're in asia you see
some futuristic [__] you don't see in
europe and america
and all that stuff kind of
it helps for inspiration for creating
products in some indirect ways as well
um so that's pretty much what i've been
doing and i think it's i've been trying
to be like radically honest like i know
this this american guy who pushes the
radical honesty movement um so i'm
trying to do that in my personal life
i'm trying to do it on the internet i'm
not perfect but i'm trying to be as
honest and open as possible
uh
because i don't like this fake corporate
stuff and it's because i started
business administration and i have a
master's degree in it so i know all the
management consultancy [__] you know
i've been there i've done that i know
that's where my friends work i know
investment bankers and i hate that that
a lot of that world where it's like fake
and not real and i
uh want to be very open and honest and i
think it's also a little bit of a
european thing not to slack off
americans i love america but like um
in europe people are very uh
a little bit more direct and a little
bit more uh straightforward
and uh
i think that comes across in my in the
stuff i do a little bit so what's the
total size of all your of all your
projects in terms of top line and bottom
line revenue and isn't it true that
you're the only full-time person and how
many contractors are you using yeah so i
have one customer support contractor
part-time uh isabelle and she works for
all my projects um and i have a
moderator for the slack group because
dude slack groups they there's some
drama in there like i've had some crazy
drama in these sledge groups in
communities so you need to have a
moderator you need to have rules and you
need to have a you cannot just automate
this moderation away like i tried that
but you need a real person there to you
know check on messages and stuff
um and then i have a
devops guy he's my best friend daniel
and he uh
works kind of like a sls sla like a
service level agreement where if the
server goes down he gets a message you
know if i'm sleeping with something he
brings it back up but the problem is
never was down anymore like it doesn't
we haven't really had that for years so
um he does security updates and stuff
you know like because i have a vps i
don't use amazon i use a vps on
digitalocean and linode um and
he kind of keeps that stuff safe you
know so that's good
and how big is the business top playing
i'm sorry how big is the business um
so remote case the job board it's the
biggest business makes the most money
normally this is starting to grow though
it's like it's past i think 100k this
month 100k a month um so almost like a
million dollar business
um remote case 1.6 million a year i
think
um
and rebase is a new business it's an
immigration agency so i want to help
remote workers immigrate to
countries that want to attract remote
workers with like you know beneficial
tax stuff uh portugal is one of the
first ones to do that um so those are
the three businesses really make money
and the rest doesn't really make money a
lot like the book makes like i think
like 4k a month so but everything you do
is part of one flywheel so
i've looked at
your kind of like system
and i've looked at a bunch of people
because i got into a little pickle where
i was like god i'm doing so many things
and i want to do all these things i'm
interested in all these things
but [__] you know am i going to be able
to juggle five different things i got a
podcast i have a vc fund i have my
e-commerce business i have a newsletter
business i have
um you know i don't even know what else
course business i got i got another [__]
right so it's like
uh am i going to be able to do this and
what i saw that you did i like i have
this kind of like mental model of a
solopreneur and a solopreneur nobody's
actually solo everybody's got like a
little support team around them that's
like helpful some some in a big way some
in a small way but basically it's like
somebody who builds a personal brand and
then builds a bit builds a successful
business and lifestyle around that
and what i noticed was that you had this
formula which is i don't know if it's
intentional or unintentional but i'll
say it out loud because here's my my
read of your business
it's basically
you ha he starts with the red pill so a
red pill is like you know that scene in
the matrix where morpheus is holding out
a blue pill a red bull he's like you
know do you want do you want the truth
or do you want to you take the blue pill
you could just go back to your normal
life just as everything was you could
forget this ever happened and neil's
like no i need to know the truth what's
the truth he takes the red pill and
basically it's like
every great solopreneur i think starts
with one truth so like uh tim ferriss's
truth was basically that like
the nine to five work in a cubicle for
40 years model
is like effing broken and you don't need
to do it that way like you could work
four hours a week and live like a
millionaire and so that was like tim
ferriss's red pill and yours was
basically like this idea of being a
nomad a digital nomad um which was like
hey yeah you don't have to
you know prescribe to the subscribe to
the
normal way of living you pick a a place
that's where you are from that's where
you live and you pay
you know you just kind of stay where you
grew up and like and you go to an office
every day and like you have to wear
shoes and whatever you're like no i wear
flip-flops i walk around on beaches i
just kind of go wherever i feel like
whenever i feel like and i carry a
little like backpack and that's my life
um yeah
so you start with the red pill then you
be then you create content around that
red pill says you talking about that
lifestyle and sharing everything from
like hey people always ask what i keep
in my backpack for the day here's what
it is it's like yeah there's every bit
of content you can come up with that's
like poppy that's like fits that red
pill so then you be that big gives you
authority on that subject so you become
like a
authority
and so you know pomp became an authority
around bitcoin and tim ferriss became an
authority around life hacking and you've
become an authority around nomadism
and then you take that and then you
basically spin off one of many
businesses that can come up with it but
every one of those business either it's
a big money maker or it's just another
funnel and more content more new
audience that's gonna like get sucked
into that same red pill lifestyle that
you are like talking about and so it
even though you're doing six things
they're all actually part of one
flywheel and every one that you do is
gonna feed it either because it's gonna
give you a bunch of cash that lets you
fund this lifestyle in a bigger and
better way or it's gonna give you new
content new stories new things to be
known about um that fit that lifestyle
as well that's how i see it i'm curious
is that a good is that traffic is really
accurate and
my thing started when i was i was
blogging just like you said i was
blogging about like nomading
um but i was blogging for my mom because
back then you had like travel bloggers
like 2013 and i was going to travel
kinda and nomad and i wanted to you know
every place i went i wrote a little
i was this city to live in and stuff and
what happened all the crazy [__] that
happened to me and my mom was reading
that um but i wrote it in english
because my mom was obviously dutch but i
was like okay she can read english so
it's maybe easier to get more traffic
and stuff more audience but it wasn't
like super like a big idea it just kind
of happened
and then those blogs started showing up
on hacker news and i started writing
more about like bootstrapping startups
as a nomad in in thailand or something
or in asia and those started going on
hacking is really high and i think that
was the time it was like 2013 2014 there
was a time when i noticed that um
the developers in san francisco worked
for all the startups they also were
realizing okay maybe i can start doing
this remotely because remote work was
not cool back then and nobody was not
cool back then because you had the tim
ferriss wave in 2008 it's like the first
nomad wave but
there was i love tim ferriss but there
was something about the the followers
there and the the business that were
created they were kind of like
like shady there was a lot of shady [__]
i met i came across in asia in thailand
like
americans and europeans it was like a
lot of brain supplements and [__] like
do it yes yes dudes yeah drug dealers
online directories and like spam daxing
and like
they're still shady [__] but less and i
was like i really hate this shady [__] i
don't feel like part of the scene
uh i think it would be cool to make it
more like uh you know mainstream like
reputable businesses reputable jobs that
do it um so i kept blogging about it and
it kept taking off in hacker news and uh
and you're right i think and then i went
on twitter and i think i kind of
organically people started following me
and then
a lot of people went nomad a lot of my
friends went nomad because i was
blogging and they became my friends now
um
and yeah and then i started all those
businesses and but i think it's it's not
like some it sounds very like a
constructive it's not a master plan no
it's not a master plan it's very organic
like uh
i kind of try i'm like user zero i try
to build stuff for myself
and i always have like i have like new
ideas like there's just like you said
red build there's like something that's
a discongruence in society and what i'm
thinking
and most people then think like okay
there must be wrong something there must
be something wrong with me but i think
like arrogance i think there must be
something wrong with society maybe this
is like a new thing so i'll try and make
a little website about it like inflation
like three years ago or two years ago i
was tweeting about inflation like this
shit's gonna go crazy with all the fat
printing money and everyone's like nah
inflation is fine stop stop whining
about it i'm like no i'll just prove you
that the real inflation numbers are
higher so i made this inflationchart.com
website that shows the inflation numbers
are really high turned out to be true
kind of now so
yeah that's all great what what uh
technology are you using to build those
sites because they all do look alike and
you seem like you can spin them up like
really quickly
well that's really funny because i get a
lot of criticism for the technology i
use i use php because that's the
language i knew because i was making a
blog like right like wordpress so i knew
php a little bit
so i was like okay i just need to write
with the language i know because i don't
know under other languages and i did
that and then i use javascript and i use
jquery so everybody starts laughing now
because jquery is like way pass a but i
still use it because it's so easy to you
know make a button bind an event to it
age exterior to the server to the php
script does something with the database
sends it back
and it works for me really well and i
think it doesn't matter what you use but
as long as you use something that's
really fast
um feedback loop and iterative loop
where you can really quickly develop
like i can make a new button in like you
know 20 seconds and deploy to the server
it's really fast and i know other
developer friends of mine use a very big
stack all those you know kubernetes and
all the stuff all these keywords i don't
really know and for them it takes
sometimes like you know an hour or maybe
even days to
deploy a new feature
and i think what we learned from startup
and lean startup is that the customer
feedback
loop has to be very difficult to be very
fast iterative so you can really quickly
change stuff and it also makes your
customers really happy because they see
something they have a problem or a
feature idea you can really quickly
build it
and then they see it and that's
i mean if you want happy customers
that's how you get it you make something
for them they're like oh my god i
influenced this product
and uh yeah so that works for me so very
very simple stack
we won't laugh at you because
not because we're nice we just we don't
know anything about i don't know what
jquery is
neither the samsung i mean nobody these
days
you're safe here
we're too dumb to to call you out on any
of your technical nice nice it's a good
podcast what do you what do you think
what do you think this whole your whole
thing's worth
because
if you go okay so depends if you do 5x
sorry sean go to his like sites and you
could see like it's like something slash
open it's usually like the website slash
open and then like it says like so many
stats most of which honestly are kind of
useless but it's just like it's cool uh
it's like you know like how many seventy
percent of them are like you know the
equivalent of like a step counter it's
like uh it's like oh how many dms did i
get today how many uh no i don't need it
no you do you have it but it's
collective it's like dm sense you know
it's collective events yeah but
for example i'm on nomadlist.com which
you said yeah i think your biggest one
slash open and on it you see the revenue
chart you see you know co2 removed from
the atmosphere you see the full p l you
see a bunch of other things and one of
them that you see is my okay so 73
profit margin your team says 0.78
so i guess that's like part part-time
yeah like full-time equivalent like fta
yeah
and then plus 492 bots
what is that service yeah yeah yeah so
uh
he has the valuation too he is if you
scroll down it says we sold for
i mean it's not super accurate i did
business but it's the pe ratio of public
companies that are similar in industry
and i try like sync it to that sometimes
um
but the dude it completely depends on
the multiple somebody's going to pay for
it right like uh have you seen those
those are extremely low no i've sold
nothing
i've been in selling processes with
previous guests on your podcast
you know so uh but it kind of bounced
off i'm just a lot of i think i'm just
going to guess it was andrew wilkinson
because he loved manchester united yeah
because he loves john boards that that's
just a guess
i can't say anything but 80 i signed any
80 of the acquisitions they bounce off
right so
right now i'm like i don't really care
uh
i like that i have cash flow and my life
is nice and but i
until recently i was really like until
like a few years ago i was like obsessed
by the selling because you build a
startup
like in the movie like social well not
the movie social network but in big
movies about startups they're like oh my
god grow big and sell and you're a
millionaire
but then if you become millionaire
yourself with your cash flow you're like
okay why does it matter actually
well let's actually talk about that
because what's interesting about you is
you have a few that you could sell so
like remote okay and nomad lists are
both pretty cool
have you calculated like how much money
you want and how long it's going to take
you to get there via cash flow and if
it's better to like well why don't i
just sell one and i can get like an
eight or ten million dollar lump sum but
then i still on this other one that's
making like yeah three million dollars i
mean have you thought have you done that
math and and what are you doing
the thing is most of my revenue is
profit like the margins are really high
especially remote okay it's like it's
like 94 margin uh pre-tax so it's very
high um
so i'd say
10x after thanks gets interesting i
think the problems with bootstrap
companies you usually get three four
five x
uh profit or review which is too low for
me it's like i can i might as well wait
three years or four years and sit in
this chair and the sites will probably
keep running because they're fully
automated and i barely need to work on
them they kind of just keep going it's
like heavily automated like really heavy
heavy uh it's just that i won't build
new features anymore then and
the site will start looking a little bit
old because you know design trends
change but generally it will keep
running so it doesn't make sense for me
to sell
for you know 5x or 4x if i might as well
wait and also like normal this is like
my baby so if i sell it
uh they're gonna [__] it up i already
know
because they always do
um like let's say
a big a big remote startup buys it okay
i know vc fund remote startups are cool
but they're also going to be bought by
big boring companies later like
corporate companies right
and they're going to shut this [__] down
they're like and this is my contribution
this is my life's work it's like a
legacy so uh remote okay i care less
because it's a job board job is not very
interesting but normally this is like
this whole
movement and culture and and there's
like tens of thousands of people on
there and my friends are on there and
it's like this
work of love you know and um
so yeah it's hard it would be hard to
sell that because people are going to
[__] it up
are you the largest
go ahead sean well one thing i was going
to say you tweeted out something that
said a 10-year overnight success which i
think is a common uh
uh idea that most people don't don't
realize which is
by the time you hear about something you
don't know the 10 years of kind of
toiling and tweaking and iterating that
it took before the big kind of
breakthroughs happen i had my life was
the same way you know i started my first
startup when i was 20 21.
and i made my first million by the time
i was 30 or 31 right like it wasn't it
took 10 years
and um and you know and then and then
every year since then a bunch of great
stuff has happened but like it took a
long time to get that breakthrough and i
was looking at your chart sam i don't
know if you saw this tweet that he has
but the chart basically shows i think
you start the sum of all my revenue
together in one chart yeah yeah it's all
your revenue from all your projects all
together in one chart and it's looking
like it's like i don't know 2012 or 2013
start
and basically if i go all the way up
until let's call it 2019
you're at maybe
600 700k and
per year in revenue and only in the last
like like kind of the pandemic boom
you know let's say 2020. from 2020 you
went from under a million dollars to 2.5
million a year right so you two and yeah
x and you like it's because it sounds
amazing wow this dude's making almost
three million a year it's like
yeah but he's also been
building that momentum and stacking
these assets and it just really took off
and which i'm guessing is like pandemic
fueled a lot of people wanting to be
nomads and like you were there to catch
that wave you were the guy ready to
catch yeah but now he this was coming
like right this was
like i did this presentation in 2015
where i predicted there would be one
billion remote workers in 2030
and everybody laughed at me and i was
like even in the comments like youtube
comments were like this is ridiculous
whereas your sources is [__] and
then confident happened and it suddenly
seems very reasonable and but nobody
could have seen this coming and i had no
idea i was actually kind of like
thinking like you know of it or what
exactly
but it kind of like it if you look at
the chart it's kind of like you know it
doesn't really go anywhere and i was
like thinking okay this is [__] like
i i tried
i tried everything to make it grow and
sometimes it grew and sometimes it
didn't but generally it wasn't very
it wasn't like a vc startup where like
well it looks like there's these p
there's these run-ups and then a plateau
and run-up in a plateau which is by the
way that's how all progress actually
looks if you zoom out
and i remember that like
during 2014 when i first moved to
silicon valley there was a small group
of people like you this i think when you
created that first slack community that
was like nah being a nomad is the way to
go and um yeah but those people were
like freaks you know they were they were
very
yes
and but there were some people who took
the red pill at that time i think steph
smith
who was just also worked at the hustlers
she met you in i don't know indonesia
or something like that because
um she had i think probably during that
more like that time period 2014 15 16
something like that she was one of those
people that defected then whereas now
there's like another wave and like if
you look at kind of like any lifestyle
movement it happens this way it starts
with like very i could take crypto it
starts with the the cypherpunks exactly
you're right yes they don't they hang
out in cryptography forums and they took
the pill first yeah and then came you
know the next the developers then came
the the finance bros and then it's the
same with the next music like music
genres like hip-hop like early hip-hop
and i come from electronic music so
drama-based music it was my previous
career like music producer it's the same
thing like edm taking off in the us in
2009 2010 with dubstep that's what broke
edm and u.s that kind of stuff it
you like these these movements these
scenes are almost dead and then suddenly
something happens like
right and it's so unpredictable you have
no clue what's going on you can only
surf it so i think the metaphor of
surfing is very accurate
it's better to serve these waves
in general i think life just surf waves
stop trying to control it
uh just serve it and kind of like you
know pivoting like pivoting startups
into that's pretty much just serving
like steering the surfboard over the
waves because you cannot you cannot
control the market at all you cannot
control society at all you know
one of the things that bothers me about
the this indie hacker movement is well i
i just i really i really like it i like
it but in general what i don't like
about it is like people think pretty
small so they're like
uh you know like there's it's kind of
related to like the fire movement which
is like oh i just want to save a little
bit of money so i can make 40 000 a year
in passive income and and i'm like oh
that's cool like getting your first step
is cool but like that can't be it with
life like you have to like you know
you're going to want more you want to do
more things and contribute to society
and with a lot of these indie hackers
they kind of come up with silly stuff
where it's like a small widget that they
sell for four dollars a month and they
hope that they can get to a thousand
dollars a month and i'm like man that's
like neat if you're just starting out
but i think that this could be bigger
and you're actually one of the few
people that i've seen go harder you know
you're going harder on this
um are there any others like do you
think i'm going harder on it
like well your numbers are bigger like
it's like like it's it's substantial
like your numbers are nice already and
it could be survivor
bias right
well yeah definitely but i still think
that there's a mindset of like
um
like for example your twitter bio thing
says your meter is going to three
million i would say most people who are
indie hackers and makers and kind of
like the the sort of tinkerer community
they don't even have their meter to
their their meter you know initially is
going to start much lower sixty thousand
or seventy thousand a year yeah and
maybe yours did too but then you like oh
cool i filled up that meter i leveled it
up so what was your like initial goal
was it like making enough to not need a
job or where did you start when did you
get more ambitious
so i i mean back when i started i had a
youtube channel for this electronic
music i was making and stuff and i was
making like a few thousand dollars from
youtube adsense so i had some runway
uh some cash flow to live off of travel
off and work on mini startups but it was
very fast it was shrinking because of
the competitive like the copyright
claims on youtube in 2012 and stuff so
it was pretty much becoming like below a
thousand dollars a month um
but uh
so i had that cash show but
to go to your question i think it's a
power law like you always have a few
people in a scene who will make more
money or get more successful and stuff
also there's a delay effect i started in
2013 or 2014. all these indeed this
indie scene didn't really it wasn't cool
until maybe i think 2018 or something
2017.
so these people that are going into it
now they're just starting kind of and
i think the widget thing is interesting
because you said it's only a widget
uh
if you make one feature really well that
solves like one problem you can get some
customers and you get some cash flow and
then you can build a second feature and
you can slowly scale up uh to a bigger
to a real business to real product
toolkit right
and then i think another thing is you
don't see a lot of people with
multi-million revenue because they
will quickly raise pc like once you pass
a million dollars a year they will
switch to okay let's go big let's go
become a billion dollar company and i
think i'm the exception i'm like i don't
want to be building another company i'm
fine like like this kind of chill um and
that's why you don't see those people a
lot because i do know them and they
quickly disappear
like this app we're using now uh
riverside i think is raised pc now
started bootstrapped and then i think
oprah winfrey used it and because it's
my friend nandov he makes it he's like
dude overwhelmed for you so i'm like oh
my god this is crazy he's like yeah i
think i'm gonna raise pc i'm like okay
yeah you should do that uh
because they think this is like this
could be bigger than just a few million
right
so you tweeted something out the other
day that's related to this you go not
sure if people realize it but if your
app does twenty thousand a month on
revenue you're probably already a
millionaire
twenty thousand dollars per month times
twelve months assume you could sell for
let's call it four or five multiple yeah
that's a million dollar selling price
right you're sitting on a million dollar
asset and when you put it that way i
think that sounds
and it is way more achievable
than this idea of like i got to build a
million dollar business like i don't
know i don't do i have the big idea
whatever
but getting something to 20 to 30 000 a
month in revenue seems approachable
right it's approachable and that's kind
of awesome i think that's an amazing
like just a
like you didn't all you did is you said
something that was true out loud and i
think if more people heard that that's
why i'm kind of bring it up here i think
if more people heard that that is a
pathway
to a millionaire status that does not
require like winning the startup lottery
of like inventing the next big thing
or working and saving and you know
paying your crazy w-2 taxes for like you
know 15-20 years to get the same same
outcome
yeah
exactly yeah i agree yeah and i think
it's it's reachable especially if you
think about high automation very high
margins so software business you you're
not going to hire a big team of 10
people immediately
you work with part-time contracts like i
do
and you keep your margins very very high
because then you can sell for 5x right
then your revenue is almost your profit
so it's the same
um
yeah i think 20k brainstorm or business
together that could get to 20k so what's
an idea
that you
you're not currently building but you
thought of because i'm sure you're an
idea guy and you think uh you can make a
website that does x or you could make
nomad lists for this other niche or you
could make
you know um the the
immigration one for this other thing so
what's a business let's brainstorm a
business together what's a business that
you think could get somebody to this
millionaire status
dude i think what's man it's like again
this is so personal so i've been living
like i used to live in hostels right in
like dorms in 2014 i didn't have money
shared with six people like crazy then i
started like private rooms in hotels
then the rooms got a little bit more
luxurious because i had more money and
then i started discovering like
apartment hotels
and
it sounds like [__] but it works so
well with remote work so i mean i was
part of the hotel right now in europe on
the beach and there's a kitchen what's
an apartment hotel what does that mean
sorry apartment hotel is essentially a
hotel so full service
furnished nice interior hotel room but
you also have a kitchen you have a
bedroom you have a living room you have
it you know it's very big it's pretty
much like an airbnb but you pay per
month or per night or whatever you pay
per month well you can pay for a night
you can pay for a month it's just like
sean um
it's like that guy or whatever yeah it's
like saunder and it's like all uh i
forget the other one the guy was
supposed to come on the podium canceled
you did one of these in nashville right
or something where you're like this is
awesome
it's working
yeah it's like a it's basically just an
apartment that you can rent for five
days and they're pretty cool i do i do
them all the time the problem that i've
experienced is within new york it's like
10 grand a month and it's like 600
square feet so that's why i tend to go
airbnb but i'm in smaller less expensive
cities you can get like a thousand
square foot place for like six thousand
a month and it's just it's basically uh
an apart apartment building that has one
floor or all floors dedicated to airbnbs
yeah the problem of airbnb is that i've
noticed the quality is very very
high there's a big range of quality
and there's problems there's no daily
cleaning
it's it feels too much like um
unexpected like you don't know what's
gonna happen the water stuff might break
if things break here you just get a new
apartment right and i've done this in
europe and i've done this in asia too in
thailand and i spend about you see two
to three k three and a half k so it's a
lot of money it's more than normal rent
but the cool thing is that it it solves
a lot of problems you have in your daily
life um because it's surface and stuff
and
it's it's a huge thing in asia it's a
huge thing in in southeast asia even in
korea taiwan and stuff so i think that's
going to be
bigger because of remote work because
you have remote workers even with
families with kids and you don't want to
live in a hotel or a hotel room is very
depressing like i go insane in hotel
rooms it's just like a bed and you can
barely walk around the bed there's no
space i need to cook food i need to buy
steak from the local butcher i need to
cook it with broccoli and spinach and
with my friends and stuff and you can do
it in an apartment hotel and i think
the
if you target it's a high-end market i
think of remote workers that make a lot
of money like 200k or 100k something
if you target them you can make a lot of
money because it's um
service furnished so what would you
build you'd actually build an apartment
hotel or you'd build a digital product
that's a big question because i i'm a
software guy i don't wanna i don't wanna
own stuff i don't wanna have all this i
don't even wanna buy land i don't even
want to buy a house i want to be able to
be a consumer a customer of these kind
of things right but i wanted long term i
want to be able to rent for like six
months you know or 12 months even
i want to be guaranteed to stay
so we uh my wife and i are like we're at
the point where we're gonna start having
kids soon and i live not like you
entirely but a little bit where we spend
we spend half the year one place half a
year at the other place
and what we're going to do next year is
just rent do a 12 month month lease in
new york and just not be there all the
time but i'm looking to rent all of my
furniture and i've been looking at a
place where
i was like all right i just want to like
book this one place and i want to pay
someone like three grand a month but
they have to show up before i arrive
they've got to completely set it up yes
and it's gonna be 100 furnished for me
and i've been looking at these and
there's a few startups in the space that
are doing furniture rental and furniture
rental is not popular right now and i
tell people all the time i'm like i just
want to rent all my furniture i don't
want to own any of it and they
they think it's nonsense and they think
it's crazy but if you run the math it's
significantly like it's about the same
in terms of price
but in terms of headache i think it's a
thousand times better and that's another
yeah
yes yeah so it's it's all about the
headaches so if you can afford it you
can reduce the headaches of
ownership and ownership uh it sounds so
privileged though but whatever it
ownership is a big hassle [__] breaks
all the time and if you are like if i
spend my time
on my laptop building on these apps it's
probably better use of my time than
managing all this this stuff and
if a company can specialize in you know
managing this stuff and renting it to
you it's much better i think that's a
real you're on point that's a real
business and
um imagine you can go to a website you
can say like okay you can choose
different sets of furniture different
interior stuff
paintings on the wall or whatever and
you can just click and you arrive and
it's already done for you like you said
i think that would be really interesting
uh yeah
what what else
yeah things that you're interested in
either kind of niche categories or
things in your lifestyle that you're
like huh i do this lifestyle thing
differently than people
this could be
you could build a business around this
i think that the biggest problem with
the digital nomad thing is that there's
a maybe it's a good big podcast just to
say that uh there's a perception that
people travel really fast and i have the
data that they don't travel fast they
travel like every few months or even i
think the average is seven months now
it's very slow so the the word digital
moment is it's a horrible word of course
we have so many connotations but it's
mostly remote working people
who want a little bit of a different
life want to see different places a
little bit um you know they have
boyfriends girlfriends wives husbands
they have kids even this family is doing
this as well
moving around every week doesn't really
work
being very slow is big and
if people are more aware of that they
can find
a lot of products built for this long
term slow mad market which most of us
are we're mostly slo-mats and
i'm a little mad also
slow meds yes think about education
think about like homeschooling is taking
off also because of remote work uh if i
have kids i i don't know if i want to
put him in a regular school maybe you
know elon musk builds his own school
that's kind of cool
but you can do things in a different way
and
like now it's still very we're still
niche like this remote work thing is
still niche it's going to get only
bigger there's only going to be more
more people doing this once physical
jobs get automated so
um if you make products i have no
specific product but if you know if you
build products for those people
that's a high-end market of like
tech workers that are most so
if you don't
but you said that you don't own stuff or
you you kind of said like you don't like
owning stuff you said that
you you said that you don't want to own
real estate so if you're making two and
a half million dollars a year in profit
this is a question that sean always asks
that i'm stealing it which is what do
you do with your money then
yeah so i'm heavy in etfs
um
i read a blog post by
what's his name the guy from google that
does seo and he's like i just put
everything into in etfs so vanguard etfs
s p 500 um but also i'm heavily invested
in asia because i believe in asia i
believe in the future i know
the west there's a lot of things about
asia that are good but it's very i still
think it's very futuristic and um i also
invest in crypto like i hold bitcoin and
ethereum um
it's always scared to say those things
on the podcast right but it's all like
very secure and stuff so
it's not exactly the most shocking thing
to us
every tech guy every tech girl is crypto
yeah exactly but i i mostly you're
actually not allowed to have that
haircut if you don't own like three yeah
you can't have a high fade with like
long top hair yeah yeah if you don't on
three
um i spend about like four five k a
month or something that's it so most of
it is just uh i do need to pay tax but
after that most of it goes to you know
etfs and stuff it's scary to invest now
because it's a scary time but
generally i'm like i want to do this for
20 30 years in etf invested and stuff
and sometimes stocks but
my i did a benchmark my s p 500 etf
outperformed all my stock decisions over
the last two years so i'm stupid just
like most people sean you want to tell
them what you did recently
what oh selling with your stocks
yeah yeah so i sold not everything but
pretty much everything sold maybe 70 80
of the stocks that i hold
um i get that i mean yeah but
yeah i'm scared they always say like
don't try and time the market so i'm
like okay i'll just sit and just crash
with the you know why didn't you do that
why don't you just like chill
uh two reasons one i didn't want to risk
a margin call because i borrowed a
little bit against my stock portfolio
but and you know to what i felt was
extremely safe and it's still safe but i
was like ah
look if this drops another you know 20
then all of a sudden
i'm having a headache that i don't want
to deal with i don't want to have to
deal with freeing up a bunch of cash
just to buffer this so i was like i
noticed that every morning i was waking
up and i was checking it and i was like
okay
logically i know
i'm in pretty good shape here but the
stress of having to think about this is
taking away from my like you know my
day-to-day quality of life it's like
that's the opposite of what i want money
to do i don't want money to give me
stress my money's supposed to take away
my stress so what did you do with the
money the opposite
what did you do with it where is that
it's in cash right now um like i might
do something like whatever some short
term you know fixed incomes type stuff
but like for now i was like again i
don't care like i don't need the two
percent i needed the peace of mind and
so that was the first thing the second
thing was
i thought what will i regret more what
do i believe more do i believe that this
is the bottom or do i believe that this
is kind of like actually
thinking that this is the bottom you
know six months in and that it's all
going to get better soon
but basically like there's three paths
either
it gets better now
it stays
this is about the bottom but we stay
here for an extended period of time one
two three four years
or it has further down to go and i
basically thought that it getting
things going up soon seemed like
the least likely thing like i would i
would actually be betting against that
heavily and so i thought okay i have
nothing to lose here in terms of upside
because i just fundamentally don't think
that stocks and everything's just going
to go ripped back up again and we're all
going to pretend like you know that was
it we just had a few months of pain and
then it all went right back up and and
remember things go things are all green
again
so i thought either it's gonna be
flats boring and sideways for a period
of time or it's gonna go down more
and i thought well in either case then i
won't regret being in cash because a i
don't have to sweat it every day i don't
have to think about it every day and b
i'm there's no i'm not losing anything
during you know by doing this and so
that was my thought process and i
figured okay there's going to be these
little bear market rallies so just sell
at the top of the next so that's what i
did everything rallied five percent i
just sold and i kept like i don't know
twenty percent still in the market and i
just put left the other eighty percent
in uh
and you know not thinking about it cash
but i held my crypto i didn't sell my
crypto
that's good yeah
are you guys mostly invested in the
american uh stock market or worldwide
yeah like you said i believe in asia i'm
like yeah i believe in asia too but i
don't know what the [__] you're talking
about how do i go invest in asia and
where would i invest i don't even know
what what does that mean are you buying
the equivalent of like an etf for like
japan or something what are you doing
dude i had a vanguard etf china and then
suddenly disappeared from my broker app
and i'm like what the [__] is happening
and i get this message they're like
vanguard left china in march or
something because they were like this is
too crazy
i don't
know got something like yeah no
privatize or did something
made private companies public or
something yeah no they they [__] jack
ma for sure there's a lot of weird [__]
happening but i still think i should be
invested in in those markets and uh
um have i told you about the jack mom
thing
how it's crazy that the third richest
man in the world that they were trying
to was like hey dude
shut up and he's like yes sir
they just took jack
my brother-in-law calls me like so we
had one moment where like a month in
when people started noticing jack ma's
missing
and my brother-in-law in the car one day
was just like where's jack ma like
if he was in the car but he's like bro
why aren't we talking about this he's
like where's jack and we just started
laughing like how crazy is that that
jack ma is just not like what if you
just couldn't find elon musk because he
said something you know that that biden
didn't like like that the idea is crazy
they did it with the tennis player too
yeah i saw that my brother-in-law still
calls me he'll be like he'll just call
me out of the blue it's been like a year
now he'll be like
yo where's jack ma and then he'll hang
up and like that's the whole call it's
so great you just feel like he's yelling
where is jack ma
but dude that's the thing with asia and
china like all the stuff is accurate
there's some crazy [__] um but the other
thing is also accurate that
there's there's lots of happening in in
asia and i think in the west in europe
and america we have a blind spot because
we get so much information that's
negative about asia especially about
china and i'm i'm not a china spy or
something my friends call me china spy
because of that but i think it's a blind
spot a little bit in the west
uh
we're gonna miss out on you know i mean
china is gonna be the biggest economy in
2030 i think by gdp
it's already the biggest economy people
pitching power parity or something
um ignoring that just you know because
there's a lot of arguments why we should
ignore china but
it sounds like a blind spot in the west
a little bit
to me
do you uh
er
what
well i'll do it we'll do an easy one do
you act you like tweeted out your
calendar and it was like free for a week
or something like that and i know sean
and i i i kind of like that sometimes i
don't like that because i'll do that for
three days and i'm like oh my god i'm so
bored it
are you is it real that you just don't
play in anything
yeah so this is the only plan thing and
it gives me stress because i'm like oh
[__] this summer's coming up um
but i mostly like i spend my days like i
live with my friends so my friends are
my neighbors now so i brought all these
nomads friends to
portugal and europe and we kind of live
together a lot of a lot of them are in
the city near here whatever everyone's
kind of near so we just have like
dinners outside and we cook food and the
sunset on the beach and just this nice
chill life that i never had because i
was alone in hotel rooms i had friends
but they were always around the world
and now they're all kind of here so i
mostly do that so i don't
want to do calls about like because what
am i going to call about like i like
having calls with you guys what am i
going to call with other people about
like new business i don't know don't you
get bored
like no because i can i because i work
on my websites right i open my make
coffee i make open my laptop meet my
friend and we code a little bit together
make a new feature um you know
then you go to the gym we go to sauna uh
we go swim
uh that kind of like but that's very
reason right this kind of chill life and
i don't get bored
as long as i ship a little bit on my
websites
i don't really get bored you're like the
only rich per so basically it's almost
always the truth
that no matter how hard you try the more
income that you make your life your
lifestyle gets inflated uh maybe
sometimes not as much but then other
times a ton and like i was like oh i'm
gonna fight it like i can't imagine
spending more than ten thousand dollars
on a car or whatever and then you make
more income you're like uh whatever who
cares um you said you spend four or five
thousand dollars a month you're one of
the few people that has acknowledged
that your lifestyle actually doesn't
seem like it's been it's it's not no at
all it's 100 on purpose like it's very
um
incidentally sometimes you spend more
right like last month was the hotels
were really booked so we had to pay a
lot of money but now it's chill again um
i think it's on purpose because i try to
follow
like last one was like 10k or something
that's still that's where you know we're
in lisbon you're making three million
dollars a year yeah but paying 10k for a
hotel is ridiculous it doesn't make any
sense like it should be the max like two
or three k for me personally but i've
seen a lot of people um
do that lifestyle inflation because i
know from corporate from again from
studying business i know the management
management people and stuff they get
paid more and they get golden handcuffs
right and they can't leave a lot of my
friends are like that and i don't want
that to happen to me i mean can't have
it to me but you get what i mean
um
and i know that material goods don't
really make me happy so i buy a new
shirt or something or i buy a new iphone
within two weeks i'm used to it and
there's studies on this there's like
research about this stuff like if you
buy a new car even if you get married
after six months you're the same
happiness if you buy a house after six
months same happiness so
if you know that stuff you know that
okay you don't really need to spend
money so much you don't need to buy
stuff essentially and
um generally it will probably make you
happier do you what do you think you
would want to spend more on let's say
that like you know food like good food
like organic
uh you know free roaming i mean it's
cliche like joe rowan right but
free roaming grass fat cow
beef you know that are happy animals
organic vegetables uh
you know that kind of stuff like not
goods you know experiences right it's on
purpose i do this what what are some of
my experiences that you think are worth
the money
what sorry what are some experiences
that are like worth the money that you
know
when most experiences
no so that's yeah you're right so man
you got me like you're trying to find
like stuff right yes i fly business guys
because no exactly i'm done with uh i i
can't sit
i only do it long haul and i only fly
like i flew only once in the last 16
months and i flew business qatar really
nice and you can lie down and sleep and
stuff
but that's about it i think and
you notice one thing i noticed like i
was in bangkok in this luxury kind of
apartment hotel stuff but it was a
little bit too luxury for me you know
and
i was there for a month and you start
noticing that you don't meet
as much interesting people like i met
one instant person who had this giant
wheat farm the biggest wheat farm in
thailand because i just legalized it was
kind of cool but generally it's a very
different it's more like a socialite
kind of paris hilton audience you know
but in the hostels you would meet crazy
people you would need backpackers but
also like researchers and entrepreneurs
and fledgling entrepreneurs you know you
met
generally more interesting people
because you were more uh in those areas
and i found the problem
yeah
sorry did i tell you about
did i tell you guys listen to this sean
did i tell you about sam corkos
from levels level other levels uh what's
the oh yeah i know yeah levels so the
the levels health the thing that goes in
your arm so this guy
so he raised yeah that's right he raised
uh so he has a startup that makes eight
figures in revenue it's worth i think it
was 400 million dollars so let's just
say that he's worth 150 million on paper
not real on paper he came over to my
house and he was with his girlfriend
and she made a comment like joking like
oh you know he always gives me a hard
time because it takes me forever to pack
but that's ridiculous i only had this
one carry-on and i was like well how
long does it take you to pack sam he
goes oh i don't pack i was like what do
you mean he's like well he had a
drawstring bag you know what a
drawstring bag it's like a bag that like
where you can get these at conferences
yes
he had that's all he had was that bag
and he goes well you see i only own the
clothes that i'm wearing right now which
is a white t-shirt a pair of pants socks
underwear and shoes i only own that plus
another pair of underwear a jacket and
uh this bag and my laptop which i have
right here on me that's literally the
only thing that i own
wait what he goes yeah i've been doing
i've been doing this for like eight
years now or something like that and i
only live and like i do what you do he's
like he does what you do peter he lives
in um like these airbnbs and hotel style
setups and he's been doing it for years
and that's all he owned and i thought
that was the craziest laundry every day
i don't understand how is he well i was
like i was like so i was like well what
if you gotta go to a funeral what if you
have to do this he goes well i just go
to a thrift store um when i need to go
and i buy stuff and then i just bring it
back and he does it partly out of i
think this is my guess he does it partly
out of
um
like convenience of not wanting to worry
about stuff i also think that there's
like a philosophy like a very
philosophical thing going on here
because it's like
extreme but have you ever heard of
anyone peter being that crazy
dude yes
actually like in 2014 i was in chiang
mai and it was an australian guy who
would fly from australia to thailand to
chiang mai with only his macbook air and
the clothes he wore and not even a bag
and he would buy everything he needed on
the spot and he would be there for like
two or three months uh and he would
donate the clothes he wore
to charity and then he would fly back to
australia with his macbook air in his
hand
i was so impressed
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago i totally missed
hubspot grow better
that see that's cool i would do that
because i think that actually adds to
the experience of traveling like
traveling fully light and then when you
get there so yeah find what you need and
then giving it away when you leave like
i'm i'd actually get down with that but
like i i rotate to underwear and i put
my underwear in my bag
no but i think it comes down to
philosophy and i do think it sounds
pretentious but i don't care
uh it comes down to
constraining your life in a certain way
i think constraints are good in
creativity in life and stuff and um
it makes you focus on the really
important things in life for you
personally it must be different for
everybody you know for me that's like
you know
girlfriend friends health food
you know happiness
all that stuff kind of and and creative
work meaningful work very important like
i need to be able to i need to have
something to do in my day i need to feel
like i'm contributing something like sam
said and uh so what do you own
so i have a backpack i have a rolling
suitcase though like a small one um i
have clothes i have a
iphone macbook
pro uh
i have a toothbrush um
you can name all the things you own
right i have two stadia control
controllers like gamepads you can use
stadia here it's kind of cool
um
yeah that's about it i think i mean
i mean i have like backup phones and
stuff because you know two-factor
authentication stuff but
it's not you think you're gonna do this
you mentioned
you could talk about your family or not
if you want but do you think you're
gonna do this when you have kids
so what does doing it mean because i'm
mostly settled down i'm also in one
place i'm just like trying to not by
doing it as in uh not owning stuff i
mean like i i think your life is cool
but you have to acknowledge that this
alternative in the sense of like you
know one percent of those
but yeah yeah for sure for sure i think
it's interesting that like the stuff i
do
may or may not become a thing because a
lot of things i did eight years ago now
are normal right so
it might be that the things that who
cares become
i mean if you're happy who cares if be
oh no it's not about me it's more like
yeah it's more like it might become
nature um
i think uh i think even if you have kids
you can do it in an alternative way you
can uh
you know you can go to thrift store get
like secondhand toys or something
secondhand clothes that kind of stuff
but
it all doesn't have to be this so
consumerist and and buying and you know
i mean it can we can do it in a
different way and
um i'm just trying to figure out like
how how i
yeah i want to do that and
we've trying to focus on yeah a
nomadless style red pill before briefly
which was um
my i forgot what it's called sam do you
remember the name of like the zero waste
project or the zero
the zero project or something like that
so basically my wife told me about this
she was like yeah you know there's like
uh like in the city in the little town
we live in
there's uh like this facebook group and
what they do is it's just like
it's like a barter it's like oh it's not
even a barter economy it's like a giving
economy so it's like if you have stuff
you just give it into the giving circle
and other people can take it out and
then they can give stuff in it's
basically like oh your kid i think it's
a lot around kids stuff like my kids
grown out of this
but that's it it doesn't make sense
right yeah like craigslist randos it's
like yeah amongst this trusted group of
people who buy nothing the same thing
but the buy nothing project yeah um and
i think i might have butchered exactly
how it works sam do you do you know a
little bit how well it's just the idea
of like um instead of like reduce reuse
recycle it like for like consumer or for
like plastic and [__] they're like no no
let's just like uh reuse we're gonna
reuse everything so instead of buying a
new toy we're gonna go get one for free
and then we're gonna give away when
we're done it's just a mindset and then
there's uh there's a bunch of companies
in the space but the big one is like
this uh buy nothing series of facebook
groups we're just like i'm gonna give
away i'm giving away these children's
clothes come get them
yeah i think i mean it's that's nice
like it doesn't make any sense you have
a baby and it grows out of its clothes
every month or something or every two
months so why would you buy everything
new if you can ask your family for
clothes they already wore whatever right
it makes more sense to me personally um
yeah
who do you want to be like who do you
who do you admire and who do you want to
be like because like
the reason why people buy [__] for their
kids is because they want to have they
want their kids to have jordan so they
look cool for other people because they
want to impress other people who do you
want to impress and who do you want to
be like you think like who do you look
up to
um
i i like derek sivers i don't know if
you know derek sivers yeah he's uh tell
me about him who is he
he's um he started a company called cd
baby in the 90s i think or in early
2000s and which was like one of the
first uh indie kind of music
distributors where you could send your
music as any uh musician and they would
press the cds for you and they would
send it to your customers and stuff and
and they also know on spotify and stuff
and he stole those for 30 million
dollars i interviewed him for my best
first thesis actually he's really nice
guy like the most nice guy in startups i
think and
he's very he writes a lot he writes a
lot of books now he's very philosophical
also kind of nomadic he's been in like
living in singapore he lived in new
zealand lived in u.s and stuff
and he's very um
if you go to his website like derek
severus.org surface.org i think
he writes very much
kind of same
concepts that i talk about like
um about simple life and and uh
yeah it's hard to describe him but i
think that's a very inspirational guy to
me
and
i don't really need to impress i think i
want to impress my parents just but
they're already happy with me so it
doesn't really matter i want to um
i want to
try and stay have like a stable you know
happiness because i've been depressed a
lot i've been anxious i had like
especially when traveling you go crazy
in these you know in hotel rooms alone
like um
traveling can can it brings you very
deep into your own self and stuff and i
think the most important of me is to
impress myself by just you know being
stable and and having a stable happy
life with with people around me and uh
yeah like kind of wholesome life you
know and that's my
what part of your life are you not
impressed by
for your either yourself or derek sivers
or if any if any of those people right
you just mentioned like the lifestyle
you mean yeah what part of your life is
not at that point where they're you you
feel like it's not impressive in that
way that that
like well like
i want to have a family too like you
guys uh and that's what i'm working on
um
and
yeah that's like that's more of a focus
now you know like pretty easy by the way
you just got to do one thing
i'll tell you to find the right
girlfriend you know and then you need to
see if they're not crazy you need to
like connect and all this stuff and i
think uh
yeah that's that's it don um
dude sean you have a yeah go ahead go
ahead go ahead i wanna hear what you say
no i mean like a little bit like you say
like
like i think about elon musk every time
elon musk presents something you're like
oh [__] like that's so cool like why am
i building shitty internet websites this
is my only life i have i'm gonna die i
should do something bigger but then i
have to like bring myself back to like
no it's cool you're doing okay like
doesn't really need to be bigger but i
mean everybody wants to make like space
rockets i guess but it's just so hard to
do that you know sean you um you have a
you have a dog right a little dog yep
i've got a big dog how do i love
yeah yeah so you like animals i love
owning animals like big aggressive
looking dogs that's what that's my thing
it's like i'm a weirdo
how do you live this the the i want to
live a little bit more like you it's and
i can do it uh a now because i have a
little bit of money so i can just like
pay for fancier airbnbs that are pet
friendly and b
i can only do it basically in america
doing this lifestyle abroad with an
animal even in america i drive you
either have to fly private or you have
to drive most places um i drive most
places how do you how do you live this
life with an animal
i don't have animals
but i want them i had i had two cats
with my ex-girlfriend and it was
actually interesting we went to in
bangkok to this this luxury apartment
hotel and they were cat friendly and it
was like this you know high society of
bangkok people with cute cats and cute
dogs and asia all the dogs are small
they like small dogs i like big dogs too
like you sam but uh and they walk around
in the hotel and it's super cute and
they have like cats and dog ice cream
and stuff and
food and they have little like a
little beds for them to sleep in and
stuff and everything is serviced and
that's another big market i think you
know
tech people with pets and stuff they
want to travel as well dude sean have
you looked into have you guys looked
into flying in america with an animal so
basically if you're why do you think i
don't go places dude
your animal's under 20 pounds right
yeah she is but like that also means
like she's not like tough enough to do
all this stuff like we're like oh god
how's she gonna handle
this experience
um you know
of going on a seven-hour flight or
whatever yeah but she she's the dog's
able to so like in term i don't i don't
know if she's physically able to but
she's allowed to you could put it in a
carrier and put it on your lap or like
in the above
whatever the suitcase thing and if you
have an animal that's above 20 pounds
who's putting their dog in the above
thing you can put your dog down
i don't know dude it's like it's like
putting a blanket over a it's like
putting a blanket over a bird cage it's
i
i don't know that's just what you put it
underneath you you put it underneath
there whatever you [__] do i don't
know i don't have one of these things
but uh
that's what they say on the directions
when you look online but uh uh like if
you have an animal above 20 pounds you
cannot bait you basically cannot this
whole emotional support animal thing
that's kind of nonsense it's kind of
getting phased out you cannot bring an
animal a dog on a flight i i'm always
amazed that for popular routes they
don't have like a once a month or twice
a month animal friendly right it's gonna
happen it's absolutely gonna happen it's
a huge growing market i think because a
lot of something rich people are not
having kids sorry right i was gonna say
i read something that one airline is
like being like yeah we'll fly pets like
i think they do a lot of pets in the
cargo or whatever because most airlines
have been phasing that out and one i
think it's southwest i forgot which
airline some airline is making bank
because they take all the pets and uh it
was like a differentiator it's like you
know bags fly free but it's like hey we
let you fly your pet and everybody else
is saying no nowadays
man i think you can do it you can i
think it's all about slow matting so if
you do if you move like every let's say
every six months
it's not that bad for the dog or the cat
uh and you you give them a stable life
in where you arrive and not too much
chaos and stuff i think it's okay i
think it's not okay if you keep moving
like every week or every month this
might be a little bit stressful for the
dog and the cat right but six months
like yeah it's okay and especially if
you get a tweet
you had a great tweet it was
if you don't have a dog in your profile
picture on twitter are you even trying
it's a growth hack it's the biggest
growth right sam has one right you have
a facebook picture i think uh yeah you
can guys use this on tinder right this
was a dinner dating trick like you you
because they swipe right for the dog not
for you but they still swipe right so
yeah i've noticed there's like two hacks
when i was single if like if i ever walk
around with like a niece or a nephew or
like a kid uh that's like an automatic
door opener to meet women and then the
other one was having a a
an aggressive but nice looking dog it's
like
doors i'm all they're disarmed we're
good you know
and why does that be aggressive but
aggressive looking but nice is that one
of those things where it's like
dog owners look like they're pets and so
if your dog looks a certain way they'll
think that about you
they want to heal you you know like
women want to heal you sometimes they're
like it's like seeing a guy with like a
sleeve tattoos who smokes cigarettes in
a tattoo under his eye who like you know
just wants to like spend time and cuddle
you know like it's like so it's really
good it's you know you're
you're you're eclectic
i don't know it just works don't ask me
uh that just works
yeah um
so dude i love summer yet dogs by the
way the big white polar bear dog right
and i think it's very strange like it's
it's so fluffy it's like that's a very
asian move of you that's they're very
popular in asia right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i've seen him here too yet but yeah
what are some
is there anything that people assume
about your life and your lifestyle and
your businesses
uh that you like for example with the
hustle as well as sean's milk road a lot
of people are like oh that's it it's
just a [__] newsletter you just write
these these words and you just hit send
that's so easy anyone can do it and it's
like well no it's actually like a user
acquisition play like you gotta know how
to do that and then it's also like
you're just not good at writing like you
have to be good and that's just talent
you either have it or you don't and so
that that's like some misconceptions
about our businesses what about yours is
there anything that um
people always assume and you're like no
because like people can anyone can copy
you
yeah i think generally people think that
every
uh website or app or company
they're a customer of that it's more
simple than actually is because you
can't see behind the hood and it's
actually way more complicated than you
think because there's so many edge cases
in every business that you need to code
like if statements for or build like
little scripts for
special features
it's much more complicated and i think
people realize that when they start
because people always clone you right
like they make a copycat of your website
and somehow doesn't take off because
they've been able to copy the outside of
it the aesthetic kind of but they don't
know what's happening under the hood so
it's um
it's much more complicated like dude a
job board is much more complicated uh
than you think like
um [__] how do you explain this there's
so many little parts
that you know especially companies want
they want you know invoices for every
little thing they add
the price is dynamic that kind of stuff
i i changed job post pricing based on
how many people post jobs on my site for
example there's so much stuff happening
behind
the curtains that you don't see
yeah it's much more complicated i was
thinking about the misconception about
yeah sorry
and a lot of your stuff is automated to
where like you don't have to be involved
it kind of runs itself you said
everything's automated i think 99.99
and to post on your job board it ranges
from a hundred to a thousand dollars i
think whatever the huge range for sure
yeah yeah how would you for the like i'm
i'm tinkering with something that costs
many many thousands of dollars a year is
there how would you figure out how to do
that like
and so in my head i'm like [__] i gotta
hire a bunch of sales people that sucks
do you think that you could automate
most things even that are high ticketed
items
oh for sure dude i sell job post bundles
for like 50k via
stripe which is like amazing for me to
me like i'm like how do you do that that
works
so you make a page called buy bundle and
you have the this you can go to remote
okay
dot com slash buy
bundle and you'll see like a slider
where you can make your own bundle and
get a discount based on it and it's all
automated
and you add your credit cards and then
you pay you know
50k or 40k whatever and how many people
do that
oh yeah it's it's like a lot of it's
like 30 of the revenue i think bundles
no [__] so someone's use yeah using a
debit card or whatever for 50k yeah dude
these company cards this is what
this is lagging information people don't
know the company cards have been
upgraded i think because they're using
it for much more these days
really like it's a lot of money
and
i have no idea like i never thought like
i don't i'm not hiring people i don't
know how this works i just tried like
okay maybe i think companies ask me like
can we buy a few job posts for in the
future i'm like okay i'll make this
thing and
a lot of companies use this so you
figure out the features that people want
based on uh talking to them of course
dude i'm looking at the sales pages by
bundle so by 25 25 jobs is 22 000
you do something interesting on your
sales pages is you just pack it with
information that's totally the right
move
but you pack it with text like you use
icons to kind of break it up the emojis
yeah i use emojis a lot
yeah no it looks like a circus right but
it kind of works
it's not like well-designed right it's
not like minimalist design it's just
like
i just add stuff every day and it just
keeps growing but it works kind of
what's the biggest purchase someone has
made i can scroll up i got to jump
through it i got another call i got i
gotta run too peter this has been
amazing i gotta go yeah nice to meet you
sean see ya
what's uh what what has been the biggest
purchase that you've had this scrolls
all the way up to 150 000.
i think 50k or something around 50k
maybe 49. but that happens that happens
a lot
yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is crazy yeah i'm working on this
thing and like it's like 10k a year and
i'm like oh man i'm gonna have to like
get on the phone all the time yeah
seeing you is quite in inspiring
but i get annoyed if i if i need to use
like i want to use these uh location
service apis to figure out where are
people traveling to for example and it's
always like you need to do a sales call
you need to like contact us and stuff
and i get so annoyed with it and i know
people on twitter get annoyed with it
that they can't get a price
directly and sign up you know um
yeah i think it's much easier to do like
this like a sales flow
um i think it's easier i would argue
maybe for me
it's easier for you but i would actually
argue there's
there's a world where it's not effect as
effective though because i would i'm in
the same boat as use i don't want to
have to do all this crap and i'm not
naturally a sales person but when i
hired a sales team and uh they they
shockingly were shockingly good at
drumming up demand and i remember a cool
podcast with the founder of squarespace
i think it was and he was like you he's
an engineer he's like i don't want to
leave my room i don't like talking to
people i like freedom
and he goes and he goes the biggest one
a huge mistake i made was i looked down
on sales people and i looked down on
this like type of pricing where i think
i got to get him on the phone but
he was like i looked down on it and i
was wrong it was effective they dr they
created demand for a product and that
surprised me most so like yeah
i don't know i think so i think you're
right i think my problem is that it's
it's been
it's very hard to meet good salespeople
or to find them and it's unclear for me
how i how i can hire them and
um
you know i how can i rate
a person to hire them uh as a good
salesperson i don't know what's a good
salesperson
and
i i've never done outbound almost never
done outreach and stuff um
and i'm scared that if i hire sales
people i need to manage them and then
you know they might [__] up they might
start spamming everywhere in linkedin
and then it becomes like a screenshot
thing on twitter like look peter levels
is spamming with his website and stuff
that might turn bad and
i think you're right if you get the
right sales people it can work
i just i'd never
been able to you know find those people
it just matters what you're optimizing
for if you're optimizing for happiness
and a well if you're opting for
happiness and like a good life do it
your way your way is working really well
if you want to like
grow at a certain rate per year and you
want to really push it i i do think a
sales person is is you do need a sales
team but that's not what you're
optimizing for you're optimizing for
freedom so and happiness yeah and i also
think that there's this there's
different types of companies for example
there's companies that ask for a lot of
forms like they want like a w8 form like
all these us irs forms and stuff they
want you to sign everything they want
you to sign an nda and and there's some
companies that just you know enter their
credit card on stripe and it's done and
it's different customers and the
customers that ask for a lot of
questions on email they generally
convert less
for me they pay less money and they are
more of a hassle to you know do customer
support for and stuff
um
so you also you get different types of
customers if you do it all automatically
you get more kind of modern customers
that are easier to deal with i think
is there anything that we didn't talk
about that you wanted to talk about
um
no i think i think we
maybe transparency like the reason i'm
so transparent is uh
um
i think it's very like i said i think
it's very important to to to be honest
and to to show other people that you can
build a a nice indie company like this
um
by sharing every like ups and downs of
it um and instead of because everybody
else is only sharing like the good
things and the we're growing so fast and
we're hiring and we're funded and blah
blah and i think it would be cool if we
did business in a maybe in a more
wholesome way where we uh you know
share everything and share the ups and
downs and uh yeah maybe not grow super
super super big but more in a you know
wholesome manner
i have a i like that but i have a few
critiques the first is yeah i think that
if you're high so you remember buffer so
buffer uh
they did the whole stick they did it
even more extra well equally as extreme
as you i would say but they revealed one
of my inspirations for sure yeah
but they revealed everyone's salary and
they did that yeah i think they did it
as a marketing shtick they did it
because they're like well like you know
like our products okay it's good enough
but like let's come up with a cool
shtick so we stick out and it aligns
with our philosophy it's great and it
worked really well for them but i
actually think that it probably hurts
them after a while it's really hard to
do that after 100 or 150 i don't know
what the number is some amount of
employees because you're like dude i
don't want my [__] all out there and
when if i was you like i don't like like
when we sold our company i didn't
exactly reveal how much i made because
i'm like man i don't want to be a target
i don't want people to take advantage of
me i don't want to be judged in a
particular way
i don't want that type of attention so
i'd rather just say like round whole
numbers instead of like exactly no
there's a real there's a real security
risk for sure yeah
like you don't want to talk about where
you are right now yeah yeah part of it
is because
yeah for sure 100
yeah yeah 100
part of the downside but at the same
time
it's a marketing it's maybe it's agree
it agrees with your with your life
philosophy and also it's a pretty sick
marketing stick like yeah thank you yeah
i think it's all it's hard to stop it
because i've been doing it for so long
it's become part of my identity it would
be hard to like hide all this stuff now
and they're like where did this open
page go like why are you not sharing
anymore i'm like i'm just done with it
now
um
you know
yeah and i don't think it's it's this
recurring marketing machine that i think
is a big part of why uh my businesses
work became successful and why i got a
lot of audience on twitter it's because
of this
i cannot deny that so it's very hard to
quit that right once you've been doing
it for so long
yeah that's why i'm nervous about even
doing it in the first place yeah yeah
yeah you know it's kind of like a i
haven't
gone hard on youtube or any other social
platform because i'm like oh i don't
want a commitment uh like you gotta keep
up i wanted to do youtube as well and i
have the same problem yeah i'm like this
is gonna be a new recurring like
activity i need to do every week i need
to upload a video make a video yeah i
think there's a world where you could do
seasons you know like a tv show has a
season i think there's a world where you
could do seasons and do quite well but
uh
the majority of people do it like
regularly and i'm like oh man i don't
want to get on that treadmill that's
scary no i think it burns you out like
look at all the youtubers burning out
it's uh they all bail extreme yeah yeah
yeah it's extreme schedule yeah i think
this is my i think it might be
interesting if i just sit in front of
the laptop like this and i just tell the
stuff i i know and i think and instead
of writing it down and just making like
little videos uh derek savers also did
that he makes little videos about small
topics you know five minutes explain
something in the next video and so alex
for mostly is doing it uh the guy on our
pod he came on our podcast alex for
mosey he's been doing it lately and he
loves it and he and it seems it seems
like a lot kind of a lot of work but not
that much work no more work in this
podcast and i don't consider this
podcast to be too much work
um
but it works well but uh dude thanks for
coming on this has been fun i uh i hope
you you will come on more often and
we'll do a little more brainstorming
this time yeah there was super fun
thanks for having me
yeah hopefully we didn't you you said
you were nervous because we were going
to ask you no but no i don't think we
asked anything because we didn't ask
anything crazy
yeah cool there's not much to ask when
you tell everyone on the internet about
everything you do
yeah this is always when the good part
of the podcast starts right because you
end it and then like the the real [__]
hopefully not
the real stuff
i hope was was going on the whole time
it was great um yeah dude thanks this is
awesome um pimp out your stuff so it's
at levels
yeah it's a twitter.com levels io so
l-e-v-e-l-s-i-o
um and there's all the links for my
websites there so you can click from
there thanks dude thanks for coming
[Music]
you